le nucléaire a fait l'objet d'une
campagne de dénigrement digne des
chasses aux sorcières du Moyen-Âge
irrationnel
mensongère
et on peut dire que les premières fake
news
c'est là
c'était une hystérie médiatique et
collective toute ma vie
toute ma vie politique j'ai pensé que la
filière nucléaire était une chance pour
la France
et j'ai d'ailleurs été très souvent
accusé de faire partie comment dit-on du
lever nucléaire tu ne plaisanterie le
seul lobby qui existe c'est le lobby
anti-nucléaire
le levier anti-nucléaire est beaucoup
plus puissant que le biducléaire puisque
le lobby anti-nucléaire bénéficiaire
pendant des années la bienveillance
médiatique j'ai toujours été pour le
nucléaire pour une raison première
simple c'est que nous n'avons pas
d'énergie fossile
et c'est pas parce que c'est connu que
ça doit pas être appelé tout part de là
la deuxième chose
pour remplir nos objectifs
environnementaux
nous avons besoin d'une clé
les plus préoccupés
par le réchauffement climatique devait
être les premiers défenseurs du
nucléaire la vérité elle est là la
filière nucléaire
accumulée pendant 70 ans un potentiel
extraordinaire de compétences
technologiques
qui ne sert pas que pour les nucléaires
c'est une filière qui tire derrière elle
au fond toute l'industrie
et le moindre signal de remise en
question d'une clé
remet en question une filière de
formation monsieur le Président les
signaux désastreux politique
idéologique qui ont été envoyés
ont découragé les meilleurs de nos
étudiants d'aller dans la filière
nucléaire
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
la Parole du politique ça compte
et contrairement à ce qu'on dit l'action
commence par les mots et quand vous les
politiques vous avez peur du nucléaire
vous envoyez un signal que vous allez
détruire cette filière parce que
attention l'arrêter c'est la détruire